Oh
on the first day of the 2015 Norway
chess tournament everyone travelled to
the beautiful Flu gr island about 20
minutes by boat away from Stephane on
the west coast of Norway it is a small
paradise full of flowers treats plans
and even fruits and vegetables each year
50,000 new flowers are seated in this
truly inspiring place
on one side of the island you can see
the fjords while the other side borders
the open sea
among the VIPs who arrived at the island
was 913 'the world champion garry
kasparov earlier on the day he had
opened the grand chest to her I think
it's an important day for chairs uh I
guess it's the first time since GMA
World Cup in in 80s where the world
champion is competing with other leading
players on the regular basis I think
it's by creating the grunge's tool we
are offering a unique opportunity for
potential corporate sponsors to UM to
buy in something that uh well have a
long-standing value um it's it's it's
very important that the best players
there will be competing together in in
ag-1 global network and I think that it
has been is this kind of event has been
long waited by by the world of chess and
again as JJJ said wish wishes luck
because that will very much affect every
other every other form of chess played
in the world thank you all the players
were introduced and asked one or two
questions
here's Dutch GM onigiri do we have some
specific thoughts about you Gannicus
Magnus well yeah he is one of the if you
look at my scores with other players one
of the easiest opponents for me so
that's not the problem but all the
others are the others are going to be
tough yes yes you said last year that he
didn't respect your authority and what
do you say about him now well that was
kind of half half jokingly meant at the
time but I don't think there has been
any evidence since that that she does so
that's I think the situation is
unchanged and here he still has the the
bragging rights in our image individual
encounters so good frame the players
were also asked whether they would use
the confession box a new feature where
players can share their thoughts in
front of the camera during the game I
think it's an interesting way to put
some pressure on your opponent if you go
to the confessional box he's thinking
why did he go now what is going to say
so there are some advantages to it we'll
see I hope for you that many people will
join the thing is is a only smoking
player here I will ready give my
opponent some handicap because I think
it's around 10 to 15 minutes per game
because sometimes you go to smoke and
your opponent makes a move during that
time intentional or unintentional and
with this confessional I am afraid it
will become even worse level runs there
and say like oh my god I'm three minutes
420 mouton M Countdown like the actual
playing Hall of the Blitz was outside
the small harbor of the island and so
the players had a beautiful view as the
world champion in all three formats
Magnus Carlsen was obviously the
favorite but he only entered in third
place Hikaru Nakamura and at second and
the surprising winner was Maxime pasilla
gruff who had traveled from another
tournament in Spain on the same day it's
good I mean it's definitely not you know
the most important thing here but of
course it's good to play some decent
chance for once in a while and hopefully
it will give me some inspiration for
furthering tournament starting tomorrow
I know that I can do and do it in bits
when I'm in good shape so of course it
was not clear whether I would be in good
shape
I also had a bit of luck against Magnus
of course because I was just bummed on
and without a new word compensation
but then yeah things went well for me
from the start I mean I won the first
three games and so it gives a lot of
confidence and what Jinora I'm satisfied
with the way I did today I mean I felt
like the games were I I played well with
the exception of the Maxime game the
results were pretty bad somehow
okay against Magnus for example I
thought I'd defend it very well it was
very slightly worse probably but it
shouldn't have been anything special and
done at the end I mean I picked the
wrong moment kind of to try and
complicate it which i think was kind of
story of my tournament for the most
friendly games laws okay against against
Sasha as well I mean I complicate at the
wrong moment and I ended up losing that
one as well too I mean he just found the
right moves and no I'll played me
frankly so those towards the bad ones I
mean even the games I won there were
good moments and bad moments the game
against Alon I think was the most
critical I think I think I should have
just been slightly better and pressing
probably but then somehow I'd let it get
completely out of control and I was
probably very fortunate to win but split
so I mean there was good and bad I mean
probably the game against Maxine was my
bust
by far so I just played was very smooth
from start to finish but very up and
down and in a field like this of course
I mean I mean things were gonna happen
you're not going to win every game it's
not going to be smooth so just pretty
happy but I got the extra one
you